may have everyone's attention please we
have a new student what's up kitty are
you trying to make the rest of us feel
dumb I'm not trying to It's Just
Happening dear God
[Music]
woman get in loser Regina George is a
scum sucking life runer why is he by our
table I can hear you by the way can you
hear me
now you are we're going to make her pay
girls are made deranged by what's called
hormones
w o what is going
on don't worry about it dance
break
me why is it so tight I mean you've had
it since the sixth grade you're probably
maturing it's funny how a mean girl open
all the doors I've been told y I'm
George we as women have to support each
other if you need to talk to me about
anything boy troubles blackheads alcohol
poisoning I have been through it
all Rachel Hamilton builds her inhaler
with vodka oh that's how you use
it slay
Queen playay like no one's watching but
everybody's watching because you're
gorgeous hey Le fringer has what's this
per nips good
[Music]
Lord